justaret qui peut plus aller manger au
restaurant je peux plus aller manger au
restaurant arrêté dans paris
non mais ça devient dangereux cette
histoire je vais changer des
galets l'invitation
c'est la plus haute tour de cage
slp l'avocat libye
sérieusement si ces rivages je suis
peut-être le seul espion qui possèdent
des documents qui le prouvent
d'assurbanque parce que j'ai eu la
décision de justice de la ville de
moscou qui m'a compliqué parce que j'ai
fait un procès à vos services
d'espionnage ça ça fait un buzz puisque
je leur demandais mon diplôme d' espions
et donc il ya une juge qui m'a convoqué
avec le représentante du service
d'espionnage et a dit expliquez vous et
après la fois hélas elle a fait une
décision sur cinq pages et 10 devant
chez moi sur présente monsieur giraud 9
qui déclare être un ancien du kgb je
constate qu'il est d'accord je constate
qu'il a fait ses études à l'institut en
gros corps ne reporte pas ce que nous
ont fourni les documents je constate
qu'il a obtenu son diplôme et la cité et
cite le diplôme je constate qu'ils
apprennent à travailler à l'étranger et
compris en france c'est la décision de
justice la décision justice se termine
quand nice mme veil
à mathieu qui nous racontera mon livre
merci je vais changer à lire mathieu m'a
dit que guillaume avait une question
puis tout à l'heure oui alors l intérêt
de bonnes actions parce qu'on n'en peut
plus alors non mais on a vu on a vu que
cette guerre se joue beaucoup sur le
plan médiatique vous votre choix il est
très médiatisée vous l'avais dit à des
médias qui titre à tort que vous partez
faire la guerre en ukraine est-ce que
vous avez pas peur que ça puisse créer
un incident diplomatique et qui est des
gens comme medvedev qui voit sur les
réseaux qui est des français qui partent
car les gars ont une place au départ du
prix peuvent utiliser ça déjà ouf oui
l'elysée a répondu à ça à l'elysée
indique ne se posait pas formellement
bien sûr aux velléités de départ des uns
et des autres mais et donc l'état avait
un devoir sur leur donner des
informations et en revanche c'était leur
responsabilité une fois sur place
non c'est bon
nadal ya les versions pour sergei oui
sergei j'aurais voulu savoir vous n'avez
pas signé de trucs comme quoi vous
n'avez pas droit de parler de faits
d'anciens travail de riches c'est un
truc quoi fesci est ce que parce que
c'est vrai que les gens disent beaucoup
que vous parle énormément pour un mais
pour un espion et du coup est ce que
vous risquez pas mal
non oui mais ils allaient de signer un
truc il faut bien préciser que
alors il faut bien préciser que moi j'ai
fait un serment solennel au kgb qui
était le bras armé du parti communiste
de l'union soviétique en décembre 1991
le kgb a cessé d'exister le parti
communiste cessé d'exister et l'urss a
cessé d'exister c'est à partir de là
toutes mes dents tout est caduque par
rapport à tout ce que j'ai si bien vous
allez je peux dire ce que je veux ça
après ils ont dit même les anciens n'ont
pas le droit de lui dire c'est leur
problème c'est pas le mien mois le pays
à qui j'ai et le kgb à qui j'ai prêté le
serment solennel n'existe plus là quand
vous recevez des menaces bien sûr bien
sûr et de deux piscines
merci on sait où tu habites on ferme sa
gueule ou ça vous aide pas moi je sais
pas où tu habites maicon daniel c
les franges tonné me lasser dernière
mais pour toi mais plutôt plus tôt
daniel de dix espions russes
rens